- Good morning!
It's time for you to see a Day
in my Life, Weekend Edition.
Look how I start my day.
You ready?
Newf, come here.
He's literally slapping
me with this tongue.
Bear, can you lay down?
Ugh, my hair's crazy.
(gargling)
Always brush your teeth
before you eat citrusy foods.
Fun fact, protects your enamel.
(gentle music)
Who's ready to make some
orange ricotta almond toast?
I know I am.
We have the navel orange
with a classic navel on it.
We have the Cara Cara orange.
Cara Cara on the right, navel on the left.
Toast bread in toaster,
or however you prefer.
Are there other ways to toast bread?
(blowtorch whooshing)
The more you can get these
important vital nutrients
from whole foods, the better,
and an orange is a great way to do that.
(upbeat music)
♪ I've been hypnotized by you ♪
Quarter inch slices on this.
God, these smell so good.
The citrus just pops.
I'm not even terrible at this.
Oof!
The beauty that is oranges.
All right, our toast is done.
Almond ricotta, check.
You know, I love honey.
Bear, do you love honey?
Speak if you love honey.
(dog barking)
(upbeat music)
♪ You always make me feel like only you ♪
Do you know that three quarters
of Americans don't get their
recommended fruit intake?
That's a problem, folks.
That is a problem.
♪ The reason I'm going out of my mind ♪
Tell me you would not eat that.
Tell me you wouldn't eat that!
I'm about to eat it myself.
That's so good.
It pops.
(upbeat music)
All right, I gotta go to work.
Working weekends is not always
the most pleasant thing,
but I think you kind of get used to it.
Unmentioned benefit of working
on a weekend, no traffic.
Even parking is easier on a weekend.
Look how empty the parking lot is.
Good morning, Ginny!
- Oh, good morning, Mike.
- Are these flowers for me? Be honest.
- Oh, yes, they are.
- You're lying.
- Beautiful tulips, yeah.
- Whose flowers are these?
- They're gorgeous, aren't they?
- Who gave them to you?
- Somebody.
- Are we seeing patients?
Are we saving lives, Ginny?
- Yes we are!
- Okay, yay!
- Today it's interesting in that
there's a really good
balance of virtual visits
and in-person appointments.
And I just did a virtual appointment
with a patient who I'm
checking in with regarding
their mental health.
We've been working on
treating their depression,
their anxiety, pain issues
that were going on as a result
of several accidents in their life.
The beauty of family medicine is
that we can think holistically.
So we look at the whole
picture, especially as a D.O.
I just want to show you
guys something cool here.
Here's our lab where
we do some of our work.
We have the microscopy here
if we're doing any kind of slides.
Here we have the urine dipstick test.
We have our strep tests,
our pregnancy tests.
Basically what happens in this room
is point-of-care testing.
Anything that you need
to do that can be done
in office happens in that room.
We're delivering those
results instantaneously
to the patient, that will allow us to make
on the spot clinical decisions.
A lot of times you don't
need a lab test in order
to get a diagnosis, but sometimes
it really helps facilitate
that process and rule conditions out.
Something else I want to
share with you is that
because we're family medicine,
we take care of pediatric patients
and we understand the
importance of development
and learning how to read and consistently
challenging our brains.
We actually have a
Reach Out & Read program
where we stock like
huge sums of books here.
And basically what we try and do is
in every pediatric appointment
is to get a child set up
with at least one new book
so they can continue reading,
continue exploring, learning
about medical subjects.
And the beauty is we have them
in multiple languages as well.
I want to introduce you to my best friend,
the interpretation cart.
While I speak okay Spanish,
when you get a complaint
like fatigue, nausea,
these really non-specific symptoms,
meaning they don't tie
directly to an illness,
you have to ask a lot of questions.
You have to get a good understanding
of what the patient is describing.
The history is probably
the most important aspect.
Having an in-person translator like this
where they can visualize the patient,
the patient can visualize the interpreter.
It goes such a long way to
helping diagnose patients.
It improves quality of care.
This is where tech comes in handy.
This is how we improve the
doctor-patient relationship
instead of harming it,
because the doctors that sit there
in the middle of patient visits
that just type the whole time,
I think that hurts more than it helps.
Ginny, can you imagine how long
we've been working together?
Are we going to celebrate our
10 year anniversary, Ginny?
- Sure, with a bottle of champagne.
- Do you have fun working with me?
- Yes, you're like a little kid, yes!
- But that's not good!
You don't want a doctor
who's a little kid.
What's up?
I heard you might watch a video or two?
- I watch a lot of videos.
- Really?
Be honest, is this guy a good boyfriend?
- He's amazing.
- Yeah?
Well, we love him here,
so we hope you love him just as much.
- I do, I love him.
- Aww, nice meeting you.
Good work, good work.
- Thank you so much. Bye!
- You get a YouTube
shout out, are you hyped?
You got hyped?
- Very very hyped. I love you, Mike.
- I love you, bro.
This is how you know, we're
passionate about our health.
Look at that pull up
bar right in the office.
Guess who's done with their shift
and gets to go home to Bear? This guy.
All right, I just pulled up
to my place, get to park up
have a little midday snack.
And you know these navel oranges
actually contain dietary fiber
which I love because we, first of all
under eat fiber, generally speaking.
Dietary fiber can help control
appetite, decrease rates
of type two diabetes, obesity,
heart disease, et cetera.
That's my midday snack right there.
And when I arrive home
the first person to greet
me is the Newfoundland.
Newfoundland! Floofy floofy.
All right, I think it's
time to take out the newf.
Newf, you ready?
He doesn't look ready.
I like to train him a little
bit before I head outside.
I feel like if I do a
few exercises with him to
re-instill his training,
he does better on walks.
Lately this guy's been slacking.
Touch.
Good boy. Sit.
The idea here is that he
waits no matter how far I go.
Okay, come.
Good boy!
The only struggle of
giving this guy treats?
Ew, you see the drool? Look at the drool!
Sit.
Oh, what a handsome fella.
Can I have a paw?
Good boy.
Nice to meet you.
Can I have the other paw?
Speak.
(dog barks)
Good boy.
Okay. Down.
Play dead!
(laughs)
Okay Bear, come on! Yeah!
So right now I'm going
to head over to the bank.
Do some errands.
He doesn't even run.
He's just hops around.
Bear, stop peeing on everything.
It's such a gorgeous day
out in New York City. Wow.
Look how good Bear is
while I'm at the ATM.
Just waiting for me, being a good boy.
One of the funniest parts
about walking with Bear is
that everyone in New York
City likes to scream,
Oh my God, look at that bear!
and I'm like, little did
you know, his name is Bear.
After walking Bear, I just
hopped in a quick shower.
I'm about to do a live stream
with an awesome university.
Talk with their pre-med
pre-health society here.
I'm really excited.
My setup is kind of really
messy here, but that's okay.
As long as the background
looks great, let's do it.
All right.
Late night sessions in the gym.
I'm hitting back today.
I'm about to do some lat pull downs.
Here. You can come watch this exercise.
Good set, high five.
Now it's time to hit the lower
lats, a little rear deltoid.
I'm going to do some low roads.
The key here is to not rush your reps.
Post gym, having a little OJ here.
Fresh squeeze action.
It's a full orange day
for me, as you can tell.
And actually juice,
post-workout; not a bad idea.
High carb load equals insulin kick.
It actually pushes the nutrients
back into your muscles.
After a hard workout
I need a little replenishment
of my glycogen stores.
So cheers.
Bear, what do you think bud?
(upbeat music)